I did that interview with the author of
uh read over here like
um it sounds like an esek guy that's my
guilty almost but you like that show
it's kind of no you know what oh it's
serious I did have I had um so I had
just finished watching I think uh
konosuba yeah uh research I think it was
I watched those two yeah someone told me
I think Goblin Slayer was also sort of
like similar because they had like
adventures in a party right yeah because
like konosuba had like you know the Mage
the yeah you know stuff like that yeah
it's also like that and I I watched I
started watching the first episode yeah
I was like oh this is like this is aqua
this is like you know because they had
the whole party yeah yeah and then it
was not like that this was not the show
I thought it was like I thought it was
like that they have like a little
adventuring party adventures and I
because I had just come from those yeah
totally different and I did not watch
another episode of that all right
okay so we
this is the guy with the best taste and
Anime out of you absolutely he thinks
this is a good anime no no this is
definitely not a good animal it's a
guilty it's a guilty pleasure I think
it's disgusting it starts off it the
main character is the Healer in the
party all right and it's like a standard
party you got your you know you got your
sword uh that's that's interesting
because usually you'd think the main
character is like the Warriors yeah like
the hero right yeah so there's no hero
there's the Mage there's you know the
the the the the the the tank and then
the main character is the Healer but
this party treats this healer like
absolute [__] like they basically treat
him like a slave just like in real video
games just like in real video games the
healer is the slave right yeah and so
it's the the anime starts off and
they're fighting the I guess the final
boss yeah all right the the Demon Lord
or whatever and they get to it and it's
a really like tough battle so much so to
the point where basically the party gets
pretty much wiped out right is it like
Sword Art when you die you die in real
life no no no this is just like a
standard fantasy world yeah right so
it's like they just so they just regular
die yeah yeah
I thought it was a video game okay so
they're on the you know they have like
maybe one HP left and they're like Hilo
man please you know help us out okay
even though we treated you like [__] and
then he was like now's my time for
revenge and basically what he does so
the main character becomes a bad guy
yeah baby basically becomes like an
antagonist right because it's like
you've treated me like [__] this whole
time and now you're begging for me to
heal you but I'm not gonna do that I've
trained up my healing power so much so
to the point where I've become Ultra
powerful basically and so what he does
is he basically kills his party
and then kills the the Demon Lord gains
his power and learns the ability to
basically go back in time but he regains
his memories
okay so what he does is he's because
he's regained his memories he basically
goes on a quest to basically relive his
life with that party that treated him
like [__] but now he's gonna try and do
the most like horrendous [__] to them
it's some like weird sick power fantasy
already killed them all yeah yeah but
he's gonna kill them again kind of like
yeah because they did some very
disturbing things to him yeah this is
one of those uh you know like those dark
what's the the name for that genre Dark
Fantasy the the ones where it's like an
evil like kind of thing and a lot of
people die
this one feels more not so much a good
story more like in cells like rambling
where did the incel part come from
yeah uh yes a lot of r word
is this this is not on Crunchyroll uh
it was on high dives it's another
streaming platform yeah uh there's too
many streaming platforms
I like the one there's like peacock now
there's a show I wanted to watch no one
uses
yeah he was telling me the show is good
yeah the second I saw I was on peacock I
was like I'm never watching it sorry
yeah because all the good TV shows are
on like different platforms there's
Severance that was only on Apple yeah
yeah it's on too many places I was like
what the [__] I I haven't got anything
Apple to them how am I gonna watch this
oh you don't use apple like anything
nothing Apple oh okay I'm not I'm not a
California boy like you well I got I
actually used to not use that oh my
family would get mad at me because the
text messages were green
that's the thing
I don't know what the difference is just
a different color the words are the same
words that's crazy I don't know what
changes most people I've met in
California all had like apple everything
it's actually like a lot of America it
actually surprised me the percentage of
people that use apple in America versus
the rest of the world because uh yeah
hearing about the blue bubble green
bubble controversy I don't even know
what it what the difference is those
words are the same I think the green one
is they have to like uh pay per text no
no no no it's it's blue is for uh iPhone
yeah yeah
you can send bigger files you can send
video files as you text yeah um but they
basically they basically
can I call it class segregation where
they're all like um in a filthy [__]
Samsung user you are [__] green
bubbles yeah that's what my family did
to me and they're like please get it so
our our family group chat is no longer
great that's so dumb like I don't want
to be judged at work I don't know what
the difference is I mean oh my God yeah
so it's basically like a soft way for
apple to make sure that if everyone is
on like one kind of system then you
pressures other people to join us
speaking of things there's a lot of I
there's no Teslas here is that there is
very little very very little I guess
you're in California
and even Las Vegas they're everywhere I
think the reason is because like there
aren't that many like charging stations
in Japan and also a lot of the streets
are just too narrow to drive Tesla steps
also in Japan produces like the most
cars in the world and Toyota runs
everything here at Nissan uh yeah Toyota
Suzuki Honda they own it all yeah uh so
they're like we don't want no you know
because if you if you have a foreign car
here it's like a it's like a seems like
a luxury car so if you drive like a BMW
or a Mercedes is like the yeah if you
have a Mercedes in Japan
yeah they're like the bends yeah like
dude dude is that crazy like that'd be
like where we live I see them a lot yeah
because in like the UK there was never
this like obviously Mercedes was still a
great brand but like it's nowhere near
like revered as much as it is they're
not like oh the bends
you're not gonna be an airline being
like oh he's got
step back
yeah I mean even even the car that
Ludwig bought for himself was a was a
little Japanese car wasn't it but that's
considerable luxury in in the states I
feel is because it's an old Japanese car
yeah right and that's like the prime
it's like a vintage car right exactly
yeah it's quirky yeah it's different
yeah very quirky